Traduttore: Fatima El Kerchaoui
Revisore: Silvia Elisabetta La Penna
(Applausi)
Quanti di voi sono degli influencer?
Alzate la mano.
Pochi, quasi nessuno.
Non siete degli influencer.
Bene, nemmeno io.
Io sono una che ha imparato
a farsi ben influenzare.
Sono una che ha imparato
a farsi consigliare.
Io leggo moltissimo in rete
e ringrazio molto
quanti hanno deciso
di raccontare in rete
ciò che sanno,
perché è così che io imparo cose nuove.
Io non sono un'influencer.
Io sono un cavo,
un cavo che collega.
Io sono un cavo
che collega e trasmette informazioni.
I cavi sono fatti di anime
e di materiale isolante.
Nel momento
in cui trasportano le informazioni,
trasmettono energia,
si scaldano
e io mi scaldo quando trasmetto energia,
quando trasmetto qualcosa.
Io faccio in modo
che questa membrana isolante
che mi separa dagli altri,
si assottigli.
In questo modo
io mi avvicino ad altri cavi.
Quando cercavo l'immagine giusta
che rappresentasse questo cavo,
ho trovato il cavo giusto.
Questo è il cavo del citofono.
Ha quattro cavi comuni
più un quinto,
che è quello che apre la porta
perchè i cavi
ci connettono,
connettono
e ci portano in posti nuovi.
Questo cavo, che poi sono io,
è anche cavo che raccoglie,
che raccoglie informazioni.
Io sono cava come quella bacinella
che mia nonna metteva al sole con l'acqua
per farmi il bagnetto.
Sono cresciuta in un paese
in cui era comune
non avere il bagno in casa.
Non vengo nè da un luogo,
né da un'epoca connessi.
Ho comprato il mio primo computer
nel 1999.
Non sono una nativa digitale.
I nativi digitali sono quelli
che sono nati circa dopo il 1985.
Ci sono delle differenze,
da paese a paese,
ma comunque sarei fuori di dieci anni.
I nativi digitali hanno l'accesso diretto
alla tecnologia e a internet.
Quando ero piccola, internet non c'era.
Il mio primo computer
l'ho comprato nel '99
e avevo 25 anni,
ma a 15 anni ho chiesto
a mio nonno di regalarmi
un corso per imparare
un linguaggio di programmazione.
Non avevo un computer.
Non avevo un computer
e non l'ho avuto per anni.
Da lì in poi ho sempre scritto
solo carta e penna.
Ho fatto in modo che comunque
le persone mi influenzassero
e nel 2003 ho aperto un blog
dove racconto un sacco di fatti miei,
spesso anche cose sulla comunicazione.
Io so esattamente
che tipo di vita voglio vivere,
lavoro compreso,
e non mi chiedo mai in che cosa
possano essermi utili gli altri
quando li incontro.
Nel momento in cui incontro gli altri
sono felice, sono contenta
di aver incontrato qualcuno
e, se mi piace, farci amicizia.
Ciononostante, nonostante il fatto
che io non mi chieda mai
se qualcuno potrà essermi utile,
io sono circondata da persone
che mi tengono compagnia
quando faccio un passo avanti
verso la conquista del mondo.
Io non sono un'influencer.
Gli influencer,
per quelli che prima
non hanno alzato la mano,
sono --
no, non sono,
perché in questo periodo
c'è una polemica in corso
e non c'è una definizione
che posso darvi che sia univoca.
Può essere utile sapere
che ognuno di noi ha
delle idee, delle opinioni,
e queste idee, queste opinioni
influenzano qualcuno.
Grazie ad internet, qualcuno in più.
Ognuno di noi
trasmette delle informazioni.
Ognuno di noi è un medium.
I mass media sono mezzi attraverso i quali
diffondiamo a indistinti destinatari
un messaggio.
Ognuno di noi è un media.
Noi trasmettiamo messaggi
e quando ci leggiamo solo online,
pensateci anche voi,
siete tutti più simpatici, più belli,
più spensierati, più magri,
leggendovi soltanto online?
Ecco, io quando incontro le persone,
visto che mi iscrivo a tutto
e quindi le persone sono ovunque,
mi piace metterle in contatto tra loro.
Quando si passano le informazioni,
nascono sempre progetti interessanti.
Quando è stata l'ultima volta che
avete consigliato un libro a qualcuno?
E l'ultima volta
che avete detto ad un amico
di andare a vedere quel film?
E quando invece
non vi è servito un parere,
un consiglio,
fosse anche soltanto
per sapere dove andare
a mangiare con gli amici
una sera a cena?
Ecco, ogni volta
che scambiamo informazioni,
diamo consigli o chiediamo un parere,
ispessiamo questa rete di contatti
tra noi e gli altri.
Io non sono al centro del mio network,
io ne sono parte, io sono un nodo
perché siamo una rete
fatta di cavi che si incrociano.
Io sono un nodo di questa rete
che trasmette informazioni ad altri.
A cosa mi serve?
Stiamo costruendo un mondo migliore,
un ecosistema fatto di cavi,
fatto di cavi che si incrociano,
di nodi, di persone che parlano
e di una trasmissione di conoscenza
che è grazie alla rete
che adesso abbiamo l'occasione di fare.
Quindi, se non siete
nativi digitali come me
e non siete degli influencer,
come non lo sono io,
potete essere un cavo.
Per farlo dovete connettervi agli altri.
Dovete essere cavo, non usarlo.
Quindi adesso giratevi
verso il vostro compagno di posto.
Chiacchierate, presentatevi, fate amicizia
Ok.
Adesso, diventate un cavo.
Grazie per la compagnia.
(Applausi)